[Musique]
une beauté
que j'aime bien révéler j'aime beaucoup
les lumières qu'on peut rencontrer les
ambiances
pour le Sénat c'était l'occasion de
montrer aussi la préoccupation qui est
la nôtre face au devenir de l'activité
industrielle dans notre pays je ne peux
pas ne pas penser que aujourd'hui
l'industrie ça n'est que 10% de notre
PIB et qu'il faut donc faire confiance
là vous avez un mot on fabrique la
matière donc c'est pour fabriquer les
idées notamment les sites des boxeurs
les t-shirts machine à tricoter
[Musique]
derrière l'industrie il y a une quantité
de savoir faire un vrai semblable il y a
des il y a des matières premières qui
sont beaucoup travaillées et les photos
Christophe Le Petit nous a présenté
voilà rondé bien courtes de ça à la fois
de la grandeur de l'industrie mais aussi
des métiers de l'industrie du geste
industriel et de tout ce que ça pouvait
représenter
et qu'à tout un problème de de des
industrialisation le travail se fait à
l'autre bout de la planète ce qui
entraîne des coûts carbone faramineux
donc pouvoir relocaliser et mettre en
avant ce qui se fait en France je trouve
que c'est une bonne opportunité
que nous avons vu ici c'est de savoir
faire l'excellence dans la diversité
[Musique]